hey how's it going guys welcome back and
we're now on episode three of making
this demo rpg
with c plus plus just going from the
ground up so if you haven't seen the
previous episode you might want to check
those out otherwise you might be a
little lost but last time we basically
finished making the basic structure of
our classes but now we want to expand
them a little bit and make them so that
they can level up so let's go ahead and
add in a level up system
and we're just going to hypothesize a
few things now what i was originally
thinking here is basically anytime you
level up the next level takes twice as
long to get to
that will keep it simple and we should
be able to just make a formula for
leveling up so in order to do this we're
going to need to have like a level in xp
in each of these classes now we don't
want to put it in every single class
necessarily so we're probably once again
going to just extend another class we're
doing a whole lot of this
making little subclasses that way we
could just reuse so let's go ahead and
make a new item make another header file
and we'll just pull this like
uh levels or well levels kind of sounds
like world level or something we don't
want to make it confusing so let's just
go with the level up
or we could call it level progression
now that kind of still sounds like a
different worlds and uh like game levels
we don't want that let's so we'll stick
with level and that's going to go ahead
and make us a header file and we're
going to make a class called
level up
and this is going to be a little bit
tricky because we got to think about
some things so when we level up like
let's say we level up a cleric we want
to go off of
these
here the hp growth the base strength and
that sort of thing so we're going to
have to come up with a system
where it levels these properly
okay very good and so we're just gonna
go ahead
and let's put some basics in here so
publicly and
privately so i think private we're gonna
go ahead and just have
a unsigned end of level and it's going
to start out as one
so
yeah
well let's use
that's one of we use one of our types
that we're using before i mean we have
our hit point types we have our stat
types
and we could
put these all in one file i kind of like
having them separate
but uh that's not entirely necessary
okay i gave it a little thought here and
i've decided how we're going to do this
level up system for now so instead of
private we are going to go protected and
we are going to use some virtual
functions here so we're going to
introduce some of that and that way we
can modify these level up functions per
class as needed and the these uh
functions will be able to access this
protected stuff and mess with it so we
do want
a
i guess you know we'll probably have a
type here but for now we'll just do a
uint
uh 16t
called level
or we'll say let's say current level
that makes it clear
and uh i should also mention i haven't
really been doing this but a lot of
times people
uh it just has a kind of a standard
they'll remember variables they'll put
like an m here or a mem or m underscore
or e you'll see a lot of that i'm not
really doing that here but uh just so
you're aware you see that that's kind of
what it means it just it's a way to
represent the variable as it's a member
of the class which and you can generally
figure out anyway by just hovering over
the variables so i don't think it's
super
a super big deal but we have current
level and we also want to have a bigger
number here for like xp so
xp if it's going to scale somewhat
exponentially this might actually end up
being a really potentially really large
number we're going to stick with
unsigned let's go for un-64 for
current exp
and
that's that should be pretty good there
now another thing we're going to want is
some virtual functions so we're going to
want a virtual
level up function now this kind of
conflicts with the name of the class
but
uh let's think about this here actually
uh
we are going to want a constructor that
gives us some default stuff so let's
just go ahead and make constructor first
here and this constructor is just going
to set current
level
equal to 1 and current
xp equal to zero
current like can i do this
current exp equals
zero i guess we could put use here for
unsigned
uh usually hey this equals plus we'll
figure that out anyway but now we'll go
ahead and just do it so if you just uh
instantiate a default level up that's
what you're going to get now what we can
do for these classes is just go public
maybe we'll say level system i actually
like that a little better so let's just
change this class name sorry to
you guys around a little bit with
changing things trying to avoid that but
it's bound to happen some
so uh sorry about that but level system
uh level system maybe there's a better
name maybe this should be like character
class level system but that's getting a
little bit
wordy at that point but i think level
systems clear enough just to say that
it's not necessarily a world level
because that sounds as odd as a level
system rate so there we go we got a bit
of a level system and now what we can do
is we can have like a function to check
if leveled up and we could have
different xp growths for each
class like maybe a cleric takes more
less xp than a warrior to level up but
we're going to avoid all that it's just
getting too complicated so i think what
we're going to do is we're just going to
put a formula in here that checks if you
leveled like any time you gain
experience so we're going to have a
boy yeah this one doesn't need to be
virtual because it's always going to be
the same i gain
exp
and all that's going to do is just take
a
unsigned
un64 you know we should probably have an
experience type at this point uh
so we can say experience type maybe
we'll do that in a minute
uh
and then we'll just add this game exp
so you can just gain an exp here and
maybe we also want to cap on this so you
can't gain like a million xp all at once
that's something for you to decide i'm
not going to worry about that too much
i'm going to assume we're going to
design our way our game in a way where
you can't suddenly gain infinite xp but
who knows sometimes people add like
console commands to their game where you
can like gain a billion xp and get to
the next level
and uh maybe that
yeah that's that's a whole another
theory crafting thing we could get into
that we're not really going to worry
about i think we're going to cap out our
level at like maybe 99 or something
we'll decide that later but we can
definitely be designing a little system
here
that allows us to just move on so gain
xp is just going to go
current exp
uh plus equals
and xp
oh
this
there and that should be it and another
thing we could do uh so you can we need
some kind of way to like say that we
leveled and uh usually how the most
games do it is if you have a level up
available
they'll give you a little icon or some
button that you press and spend your
level up and do your level up so it's
not necessarily just going to
automatically
pop up and do it although it could
but let's go ahead and make one more
variable
and just say
level ups available so this is also
going to be the same one as same type as
this level so we probably want like a
level system type or something uh but
let's go
level ups
available so that way if they're
available we can spend them and go ahead
and level up and we can check
with level ups available and current
level to see
how much current xp is needed to get to
the next one anyway so that uh that
should work pretty good there
also quick interjection here this uh
isn't sponsored by anything other than
me so consider subscribing also
if you're enjoying the series and want
to see them as they come out uh be sure
to hit the the bell because youtube
isn't going to necessarily notify you
when new episodes come out you have to
hit the bell to manually get that going
on so just throwing that out there real
quick
all right so
let's see here current level levels
available okay so what we want to do
here is just do a quick check uh
probably every time we gain xp and see
if we gain the level and we could do
that here how are we going to do it we
need to think of a system
that checks and i was thinking that we
uh we'll just make like another function
actually we could even make it private
down here like void
uh
a check it level check if
level now i kind of have this thing
where i like to have my private helper
functions uh with this underscore
case and my
my uh public functions uh in more of a
camel case
so that's just the thing i do it doesn't
really matter how you do it but just fyi
that kind of makes it clear to me which
ones are private and which ones are
public when i'm looking at it later
but everybody does it differently it's
just my organization style so what we're
going to do here we're going to
just do a check if level or level makes
sense
check it level so we need a formula here
and that's this is where things are
going to get tricky so we're going to
start out our current level at 1 our xp
is 0
and we need
to to do something here so
uh we're let's just hold a local
variable anytime we call this function
and we'll make it
this
well we'll make it the xp type so
let's go ahead and make it type let's go
let's just do it right here i mean i
could make another file for this but i
think these are only going to be used
for the level system right now and we
could there is a case for doing these
hit point types in the hit points
file
directly too
because anytime you're including the hit
points you're going to want to know
about the hit point types so there's a
case for doing that in fact
let's just do it let's just go like this
it's going to reduce our files so now
we've got that typed up in there for the
hit points we can delete this file
delete and we're going to do the same
thing with our stat types just put that
right in our stat block file
uh
okay so
at least now you know though now you
know how to how to do it either way but
i think this is gonna be a little
cleaner because we're gonna just have a
million different type files if we
continued the trend of doing it the way
we were doing it
okay so let's go back to our level
system and we're going to type def
and we'll have
let's see we need xp type
exp type
uh is going to be this here
and we need another one for
uh level type
that's going to be this smaller one
level type
so for anywhere
we have that one yeah we'll just do that
and of course we're going to need to
include
rfc standard hint
here
pretty good
okay so now uh that that'll just clean
things up i like that better now that
i've thought about it so
and and just any of these right here we
just change to
exp type
and these other ones are going to be
level type
cool
now i will say again that doing this
whole type thing is optional i don't
know if i said that it just it's just
cleaner i think it's i think it's going
to be better in the long run if we do
that and it's also nicer than typing
this every time in my opinion
right i think so anyway or whatever it
may be
all right so now that we're checking if
leveled here what we want to do is we
want to hold the variable of level type
and get like the current
current
equiv
equivalent level
and that is going to equal a current
level plus level ups available because
our your current level you might be like
level let's say you're level five but
you haven't spent your level five level
up so your current level will say level
four until you spend it
so our current equivalent level is what
that's going to be if that makes sense
but that's all i'm thinking here is we
don't want to like
not take more xp to level up to the next
level just because you haven't spent
your level up just a little logic
working out here so we'll get this
current equivalent level and that way we
can check what it requires now we need
like an xp gain or xp ratio for every
level up and i was thinking just times
two every time
and maybe we'll start it at 100
for like first level and we got to
decide where we're going to hold this
variable i think we're just going to
statically hold it somewhere in this
level up system
where we can get it anywhere we want see
where
see these
these growth amounts are public over
here
we'll kind of do us a similar thing and
we'll just have like uh
xp ratio static
const
uh let's see we're gonna be doing some
multiplying i guess we'll just use
xp type
for this
and
level up multiplier
i'm trying to think of a good variable
name for this i'll probably rename it
here in a sec but it's basically how
much you
need every time because we're just going
to make it scale exponentially i think
that way it gets harder and harder to
level
like level 1 we'll take
level two we'll take 200
level three will take 400 and then 800
and so on a nice exponential times two
uh and so it's just going to be two
equals two we're doing a static const
that way this doesn't get to this
variable doesn't get created a bunch of
times that's totally not necessary
uh we could probably use a smaller type
here
but we're going to stick with yeah we'll
stick with level type it might even
yeah this is fine let's not worry about
it too much this is level type there and
we also want
uh
where you're gonna start level one so
this one's gonna be xp type i think that
makes more sense here
equal or uh starting
i will just say level one at
we'll make this 100 so you get to level
100 or level one at
or level two at 100 xp because you start
at level one level two
had 100 xp and that way it will scale up
from there so we're just going to use
these now we could even put these if
they're not used anywhere else and you
don't necessarily want to know about
them
anywhere else in the file you could just
put them literally only in this function
that way
people know not to mess with them but if
you want to make like your game moddable
and stuff you might want to expose these
somewhere where someone could change
them or maybe we'll probably get into
this part later maybe when we get to
making worlds and stuff uh sometimes
people will kind of make a system with
the code and then they'll make a
a file that they read from to do
everything for your actual game you see
this quite frequently
so we might get to that eventually it's
definitely required when saving to read
and write but
like you know text files or binary files
or something non-code files basically
that you modify at runtime so these
could be turned into runtime files this
whole thing could be
that's really a whole nother thing we'll
probably get to that at some point when
we get more advanced but we're not going
to worry up too much about runtime files
right now we're just going to make
things internal in this way
no one's allowed to just like modify
your game easily they'd have to
literally get like a binary editor to be
able to change these sort of variables
so
this is what they call hard-coded things
are hard coded into the game
so you don't necessarily need to hard
code you could soft code by saying every
time my program runs it's going to bring
in the settings it needs from a file or
something like that
so just a little food for thought
but uh yeah we'll worry about that at a
later time
if we want to go that route i don't
think we're going to go that route until
much much later anyway
if we are getting into some more
advanced little
uh things and did i spell equivalent
right or wrong that's
it's quivent
how do you spell equivalent oh gosh
sometimes when i'm coding and trying to
think of words
or variable names i just know i'm
spelling them wrong but what are you
gonna do you gotta you gotta keep moving
there we go i spelled it right
yeah all right so our level we're gonna
get the current equivalent level
no we got these variables we're gonna
use and one of these very so we need to
like
determine how much xp
that we need
uh let's think about how to do this for
a second
okay i admit my brain is a little foggy
for some reason right now i'm just uh
not feeling uh
super in tune and sometimes that happens
when you're coding and what do you do in
those cases do you just stop coding uh
sometimes you just gotta press on but
let's just think about it sometimes i
like to think about these things in kind
of a chart form and that helped me now
so let's just make a little comment here
so at level one uh you'd have zero xp
zero xp needed right and level two
uh is going to need
the level two at
exp needed
right
and at level three you know you see
where this is going uh we're going to
need the level two at
times uh we need a formula we can hear
we could put in here
it's going to be the previous one this
is kind of it's going to look like a
fibonacci isn't it
yeah we're basically going to take the
level 2
xp needed or the previous
times 2
times
2 xp needed
this is kind of weird to think about
and then on level four
well we basically just want to put this
into the cleanest formula we can come up
with for life me i feel like i'm not
going to come up with the cleanest
formula and that's going to kind of make
me look like a fool but whatever i'm
going to go with if someone wants to
correct it and make it better on github
more power to you appreciate it
i'm sure someone will
but it's basically going to be this
except it's going to be uh
okay so this is a const let's let's do
something level
two at
and this is
level
multiplier or level scaler maybe scalar
makes more sense there
yeah
this is always going to be
level scalar
well basically all we want to do is we
want to take whatever experience was
needed for the previous level
times 2
and so on and we just want to put a
little formula in here
and this way we can basically have a
system
where we can level indefinitely
in theory
and we don't necessarily need the hard
cap but we probably will hard cap we
don't want to necessarily be able to
level indefinitely and at some point
it's going to get so hard to level
because like whatever's happening in the
game the monsters or whatever won't give
enough xp to to level in any amount of
reasonable time
okay so basically it's just going to
look like this so level 1 0xp level 2 we
take the level 2 at xp needed this is
kind of our main
thing we start to scale off of then at
level 3 and so on we take the previous
required times the level scaler
and it just keeps going like that just
previous required so that way we only
need to know
where we start the scale and if we want
to make it take longer we could start
the scale higher or lower or we could
kind of adjust this on the fly to make
some balance changes later if we want so
it just gives us that simple option
where we change one variable and we
change the whole how the whole
exponential scale works so a lot of cool
stuff but you can do like that with code
and level up system in my opinion you
can also do this
with uh with combat stuff too and this
is more where like this kind of theory
is where you kind of need the calculus
part
of uh an algorithms part
of computer science stuff which is
always fun
i say always fun but some people do not
enjoy this part and in fact i enjoy it
on some days some days the stuff seems
like it clicks very well for me and
other days i'm just like i don't feel
like thinking about it and today is one
of those days where i don't particularly
feel like thinking about it but we got
to push on so we're going to get this
wrote out here in the best way we can
for now
okay before we continue here we should
also set this
uh level ups available to zero in our
starting thing otherwise that could
cause some serious confusion in our
thing if this sets to some random number
so yeah zero level ups available to
start start level one okay and basically
what we do is we want to get how much is
required to get to the next level
and see if they've hit that if they have
will increase the level ups available
and that's that should pretty much take
care of it also want this case in the
beginning uh it might not be super
critical but i don't think it's going to
mess up anything too much but if your
current xp is less than 100 you're still
at level one that's the case where we
just don't even need to run any
calculations we just know that you
haven't leveled because you haven't even
got the level two yet so that just uh
you know is a kind of a base case there
and uh from here on out we should be
able to develop quick little formula
all right so let's just do this with a
for loop i guess that makes it pretty
easy so we're just gonna go
or maybe a while loop let's see while
okay i gotta think about how i'm gonna
formulate this i know i've been thinking
a lot here i'm trying to trying to get
it straightened out and say it the best
way i can to reduce confusion for you
guys
i've determined that i'm overthinking
this so i'm just going to do it a way
simpler way
okay so if you ever find yourself just
making and just a complete elaborate
mess of your code
consider just deleting all of it that's
probably the best thing you can do
and it started over because i was just
going down a rabbit hole of theory and
all i really need to do
is just double whatever it previously
was
oh aside
okay so the simplest way of doing this i
can think of is basically we just take
xp till next level
xp type
xp to next level
that'll be right this is fine to next
level
and we're going to start it at this uh
100 or level 2 at
yeah that that should be fine
and we'll just do that here
uh
yeah
easy enough right
and we'll take this scalar
now this this scalar can stay in the
function we'll still use that function
i'm just going to do it a simple place
so level 2 at 100 sure
uh and that's just something we're going
to pull this to
uh here we go xp until next level so
we're holding another variable not a
huge deal but this should make it a lot
simpler and i was also thinking uh we
don't we're not going to do this
xp or a
level equivalent we're just going to
always make your current level whatever
it truly is and whether you've spent
your points to level up not or not is on
you so that's going to be the level ups
available
and that that should be a lot better
a lot lot better
and a lot cleaner to reason about
so okay so if we gain xp we'll just add
it to the xp
and check if leveled and the only thing
we're going to do here is just
double
uh or we're just going to keep track of
whatever the xp till next level is and
see if you've hit or not it's really
going to be that simple so we do need uh
to to maintain a little bit of a level
up system in that regard
and and yeah there's there's just a lot
you can uh theorize and change here and
a lot you could do your own
particular way
but yeah this is going to make it so
that literally the only thing we need to
do here
and for the check if level
is if
current xp
is greater than
the xp needed to level
and then we'll say we level up
now whether we want to do the level up
here
or somewhere else yeah i think we're
just gonna
we're just gonna do it all here
trying to keep this as simple as
possible but yeah the naturally things
are gonna get more complex as we move on
but we will just go ahead so if your
current xp is greater than the xp till
next level
uh we're just going to do this do the
thing basically i don't know if we're
going to use this or not we'll see
but all we're going to do is go
current level
current
level
plus plus
and then
level ups available
level ups available plus plus
just increment both of those
so earlier i was saying
saying in a way where you have to spend
your level ups to increase your current
level but we're not going to do that
it's just going to automatically
increase your current level and you have
level ups to spend maybe
uh i don't even know if i'm going to use
that to be honest that that implies that
we're going to have like
a point system and skill trees and we
haven't gone the whole skill tree route
yet so maybe this whole level up system
available
uh it's
not even necessary right now so i'm
actually just going to delete it
i just don't think it's it's viable
we're just going to kind of auto
generate abilities you're going to
automatically get points you're going to
automatically get your next abilities
you're not going to need to choose thing
now if we do introduce skill trees this
whole points available thing is going to
be a thing we'll do
but for now we're going to leave it out
of the the level up system we're just
going to leave the level up system as
simplistic as possible i think that's
better
and i'm glad i thought about it but uh
yeah that's that's basically it so the
xp to next level should now double
that's
uh plus equals or times equals two
or the level scaler
and that's it so you level up and you
say the next level
has had double what it was before
i guess we'll put the scaler in here
and that is so much cleaner than
whatever the heck i was trying to
formulize before
but i'm going to leave that in there i
know it's going to be like a little
crunchy or whatever i get it but i think
it's important to realize that sometimes
these kind of things happen when you're
doing creative coding like you come up
with this whole system and it sounds
simple in your head and then you try to
implement it and it's a total mess and
basically what you have to do this is
really important
you need to step away you need to think
about things you need to consider
deleting your whole thing and starting
over basically
that's a very dramatic way of saying it
but
that was literally the best thing i
could have done like i could have sat
and thought about that problem and how i
want to do it all day or i could have
just
just done this which is so much so much
better and cleaner
okay well that's basically it for the
level system for now i don't think we
need a whole lot else i think we're just
going to go ahead and give it put it in
some of our classes test it out a little
bit and implement how it's going to go
in our classes so we do want to add in a
little bit of some some virtual method
maybe maybe it'll be in
uh
so this check if level thing it's
it's going to automatically do its thing
we probably want well we can get these
you know it actually makes sense to make
this a pure virtual
class because
this whole level up system shouldn't be
ever be its own object it belongs to
something that is leveling
and
if that's the case we want to just make
a virtual
uh
void
level up equals zero
so that way
anything that
inherits from this
is we're going to be forced to add in a
level up system
and that should
that should help out things
so maybe we could even put that here we
could put like
increment current level
level up is it going to let us call this
actually we'll do a little experiment
here
this
okay so since this is a pure virtual
class we can't instantiate it on its own
but now we have a function in here that
calls
a virtual level up
now this is where c plus gets a little
interesting let's test it on the cleric
here
so
let's uh we implemented or we brought in
this level system
let's include it
and then
let's make all the pure virtual
functions
okay so uh yeah we can go manually type
it in but visual studio has this nice
feature where you can just right click
and go implement pure virtuals for
cleric and it should do it
uh
operation failed for one of one
unable to create function level up
okay whatever so i guess going to type
it manually we go void
uh we're going to sit
level
up
override
and
we'll do a thing
now we're in an experimental zone at
this point but when we level up we just
want to uh give our
well we want to increase
some of this stuff like we want to
increase our hp we want to increase some
of our stat block stuff
that's that's basically it so when we
level up
and actually we could even make this
can we do it privately because we don't
want anyone we don't ever want to call
this this should trigger automatically
specifically when we gain xp
and check if leveled and if we leveled
it should trigger a level up so we're
kind of kind of putting a little
something like that in here and this
might not compile at first but if it
doesn't we'll analyze and we'll learn
some stuff about c plus plus so i
encourage you to give this a try even if
it doesn't work here in this video on
first try just for your learning sake so
go level up we'll go hp dot
or
what do we call it here
so we're going to go set max hp it's
basically what we're going to do
set
if it lets us
hold on
okay
i just like recorded and talked for like
10 minutes
and i just realized my recording was
paused so
oh psy okay we're gonna i'm gonna do a
little catch up here okay i'm gonna
speed run what i went over
this might actually be good for you guys
because at least now you know what i'm
gonna tell you actually works and you're
gonna get less of the experimental stuff
okay so the level up system here's what
it looks like right now
uh
geez i'm not even sure exactly where we
left off to be honest i'm not sure where
that glitch happened there
okay so the only thing we do is okay
level up system here's our current
starting values with this static
and whenever we gain xp
we're just going to add to our current
xp right we already went over that but
now we're going to check if leveled and
we put it in this while loop because
check if leveled now returns a true if
you leveled or false if you did not in
that way if you have gained enough xp to
gain multiple levels it's going to keep
checking as long as this returns true so
if you leveled up it's going to check
again to see if you leveled up yet again
and as long as you keep leveling it's
going to be like hey you got a lot of
experience you're going to keep leveling
but when it when it gets to a point
where you've gained xp but it wasn't
enough to level it's going to return
false and stop that way anytime
this should work better this way
all right we also added some just some
getter functions here
uh to get your current level get your
current xp
get xp next level that way we can
populate that into character sheets nice
and easy and putting that in the level
system it's going to just auto populate
and everything we also made this pure
virtual function not sure if i talked
about that before the recording stopped
but it's uh this equals zero here means
you must implement it and whoever
inherits from it
and
we are also calling the pure virtual
function here and check it level so when
you level up
it is going to call this pure virtual
function level of level up and this this
kind of gets interesting because
what's going to happen here is it going
to call it for the proper one is it
going to glitch out is it going to have
a compiler error well
this is you know this is a nice thing
about c plus plus here so we went ahead
and implemented it into the cleric class
and we also added a few more things here
which i think i missed so we're going to
go over that again so yes we have our
base stats here
and i made those
all base and the growth ones are for how
it levels so a little change there base
stats are what they start out as
growth i just set it basically to half
of what the starting one is rounding up
for things that are odd numbers
and uh so we got our starting ones here
in the constructor but anytime we level
up here we have privately implemented
level up so you cannot call
uh cleric.level up and that's important
but it is implemented here to be
automatically called by the level system
for this check if leveled so that's like
an interesting thing you can do with c
plus
where you can uh
kind of automatically call some of these
functions from inherited things
but not you know because you don't if
you don't have enough xp to level up you
simply can't that's the whole point here
the only thing you will be able to call
is the public function gain xp and if
you have enough xp to level then you
will level up and you will get
whatever happens here and all we're
doing is we're growing your max 8 hp
so we're setting max hp we don't have an
increased max hp function so i'm just
getting whatever it currently is adding
the growth and for the stats i did
implement this as well not sure if i got
this in the recording but in the stat
block we went ahead and added a increase
stats as a
protected function
i actually forgot to fill this out
totally so
uh it's all it's going to do is just
increase these as you would think
strength
plus equals s
and intellect
plus equals i it's not just a nice
little increase function we could
separate them out like increase strength
increase and i like but now you can just
pass in zero here and that'll be fine so
i thought that would be very
very good good enough sufficient
and
what next so yeah we're done there we
added that into the stat block
uh okay we're pretty much done showing
the level up system
there it is
looks looks good enough
pretty simple
i say simple but uh
i struggled with it for a minute to wrap
my head around what i wanted to do and
how i wanted to arrange that but that's
the way it goes all right so we got a
little test here where we just run a for
loop and uh we just gain xp let me see
i'm going to make sure i didn't miss
anything here yeah okay i think i think
we've covered everything of course we
got the inherit
level system and include it not sure if
i had that in the recording but just
trying to make sure anyone that's
following along doesn't get completely
lost
this episode has been a mess and but uh
it's the way it goes sometimes sometimes
coding is messy if you're able to keep
up and get keep with all this you're
doing great
and i for one am proud of you
so
let's see here yeah we just got a little
test i i deleted all the other ones for
now this is main right now while
eventually it's going to run our entire
game but for now we're just going to
kind of do tests as we go to make sure
everything's working as we expect
so we instantiate a cleric it's going to
get all that base stuff and then i'm
just running a loop i'm just doing this
twice
we're just going to spit out a pseudo
character sheet if you will it shows
your xp strength intellect level and x
and xp the xp is going to say your
current and also how much till next
level
with a little slash there like you
usually see on character sheets and
games and then at the end of this we're
going to call gain xp so the clerk is
going to gain 100 xp go to the next loop
say the character sheet again gain xp
and then it's going to exit so the last
gain xp isn't actually going to do
anything maybe we'll just put the if
statement here just for the heck if i is
less than
one so
then gain xp so that way the second time
around it's not going to gain xp it's
only going to do this once
uh yep that should be very nice so let's
go ahead and run this see what happens
and
make sure it works correctly okay so
first time through
cleric just uh base instantiation here
max hp 14
strength two intellect three looks good
level one zero of 100 xp that's pretty
good you know i'm actually going to put
this uh
level up here i think it's just going to
look nicer
level
then we'll call this git level here
i'm going to put a quote here
just keep it nice and clean there and
actually use single quotes because
that's actually just a character not a
string a little tiny optimization
and that out of there
and that looks pretty good
all right i think it also maybe the xp
should be right under the level sure
that means we've also got to move where
the semicolon is
there's a lot of different ways of doing
print out it's just my way of doing it
sometimes i even like doing it like this
because you see it nice in one nice
block
but however you want to do it's fine
let's go ahead and run that see how it
looks get out of select mode there and
there we go there's our nice little
character sheet call out looks good and
then we level up once it looks like we
do get one more strength one more or two
more intellect so that's correct and we
get seven more hp that's correct xp yeah
looks like our level up system is in
general working pretty good now what you
want to do next is just expand
these uh let's say xp growth thing and
this level up and write the same things
and for these other classes
so uh yeah let's let's go ahead and do
that real quick
so the rogue i'm just gonna do a copy
paste it should work correct we'll put
it in the rogue
we'll put in the warrior and we'll put
it in the wizard
and we just need to change
these as well
because this is now going to be
yeah let's just change this hp growth is
now going to be called base hp
little change there i might have been
saying that earlier for the clear but
when we instantiate now we're going to
call it on base hp we didn't that was a
change we did that i think i missed
recording
yes so rather than hp growth all these
base starting ones are base base base
and the growth ones for the level up is
what we're using there
so we could even put this like down here
closer but it doesn't matter that much
all right just so that's clear
and i'm just going to copy these because
it's going to be about the same so go
into our rogue
put those in there make sure let's go
half values let's actually start the
rogue at 12 because that's an even value
and increase by 6 at a time
i'm kind of want to stick with evens i'm
thinking some somewhat or round up when
we can yeah that's good i like that okay
so their strength increases by two and
like increases by one
uh base oh this needs to be
changed here
this should be base hp
and we need to change these
there we go we got hp growth yeah that
looks good
looks good
we need to include here or we need to uh
inherit also
the level of system
or level system
maybe it should be called level up
system i don't know both are pretty
close
that we want to include here of course
there we go and we're just going to do
the same thing for the warrior
rename this to base hp
so hp growth
oh let's go ahead and grab this line
here
when in doubt copy paste and set up type
but uh make sure you get it all correct
all right let's uh let's round their hp
let's actually do 18
on the warrior
and forward one's pretty good there
uh there's a few inconsistencies i'm
kind of seeing here though i'm not real
happy with like
this four and one is still gonna round
down to two and one which is the same
increase rate as
the rogue i guess that's fine sure we'll
leave it but they do have a higher
starting base so sell the warriors a
tiny bit tiny bit more strength but it's
just not going to
scale
better
over the levels which is sort of
interesting there we go level up looks
good we got base and these
uh we'll leave it for now you know we
might do some buffs and nerfs later but
just getting this initial setup going
okay wizard we already corrected the
base hp
we got uh we need some growths in here
this is going to be hp growth
and uh we just need to get these in here
for the wizard
i'm really looking forward to the part
where we start doing abilities stuff and
stuff like that let's go with 10 hp
that's a
better number there i think
and uh looks like we can go 2 1 here
that's actually the same rate as the
cleric isn't it yeah
a little less hp than the cleric that's
fine for now
level up looking good okay we need to
include
this kind of stuff here the level system
and inherit can i
just put a
i don't know if we need to keep retyping
public to be honest i think we just yes
let's make sure this all builds and runs
yeah we only got the cleric
instantiating
so that's looking pretty good there
that's looking pretty good there we
could do the same thing we could uh
could make these for every
every class here
we could go you know we could change one
of these to rogue or whatever
oops rogue
rock
and we could just do a quick test on the
road
uh we won't do all of them we'll just
just rogue only here
and just make sure that he is also
leveling correctly
let's make a couple more
new lines in between them
see out here
a bunch of lines that way we can see the
separation of the two classes there
there we go
give that a quick look make sure it
looks good you're welcome oh are we
still saying cleric yeah
hey
there we go and you know we could do
some fancy stuff like instead of having
to say rogue we could get like the class
name by uh class type yeah we could do
some fancy type stuff like that
so we don't have to manually type in the
string but we'll save that for later if
we do something like that but it looks
pretty good looks like the rogue is
increasing correctly as well
six more hp yep two straight more
strength yep okay
so yeah there we go level up system
intact thanks for watching
and uh don't forget to support the
channel if you enjoy this stuff and want
to keep seeing it does help me continue
making this sort of content because it
as you would imagine it isn't always
easy for me to continue doing this sort
of stuff every day
uh
yeah i don't want to get too much into
that but you probably get it so i just
know that i really really really
appreciate your guys support
all right good luck and let me know if
you have any questions
and we'll see in the next one peace out